mehr corona infizierte in china die
regierung korrigiert die zahl nach oben
in europa wächst die angst vor
arzneimittel engpässen letzte zeugen in
der berater affäre ex
verteidigungsministerin von der leyen
räumte vor dem untersuchungsausschuss
fehler ein und britta saison auf schalke
thomas dreesen der oberbayer gewinnt die
weltcup abfahrt in saalbach hinterglemm
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind an
meiner seite ist für den sport wieder
noch wird könnt ihr gerne schön genannt
gerade mal 44 menschen in ganz europa
haben sich bislang mit dem corona virus
infiziert trotzdem herrscht weiter hohe
alarmbereitschaft
die weltgrößte mobilfunkmesse mwc in
barcelona wurde aus sicherheitsgründen
kurzfristig abgesagt und die
eu-gesundheitsminister fürchten dass
arzneimittel in europa knapp werden
könnten weil lieferungen aus china
ausbleiben
aus brüssel berichtet ina dort rund um
die uhr sind die experten im brüssler
krisenzentrum im einsatz
sie koordinieren die hilfsgüter für
china die rückflüge der europäer und
halten die ausbreitung des corona virus
im auge in der eu und großbritannien
wurden bisher 44 fälle gemeldet 16 davon
in deutschland verschwindend gering ist
dass im vergleich zu china
in all den ländern außerhalb chinas wo
das virus aufgetreten sind wir in der
phase dass wir eindämmen wollen das
heißt also verhindern wollen dass es zu
langanhaltenden infektionsketten in der
bevölkerung kommt und das gelingt
bislang auch damit das so bleibt haben
die eu gesundheitsminister heute in
größe ständigen informationsaustausch
und enge kooperation beschlossen
reisebeschränkungen wird es nicht geben
an europäischen flughäfen sollen
reisende aus betroffenen gebieten nach
persönlichen kontakten und
infektionsrisiken befragt werden
deutschland will diese daten für 30 tage
sicher da die meisten der wirkstoffe für
herkömmliche medikamente zum beispiel
antibiotika aus china kommen soll die eu
kommission nun prüfen ob dortige
produktionsausfälle hier zur
arzneimittel knappheit führen können auf
lange sicht das ist nicht kurzfristig
möglich brauchen wir wieder auch stärker
produktionskapazitäten
wir bei uns in europa auch in
situationen wie diesen etwas so
lebenswichtigen wär's nein weil damit
auch umgehen können die suche nach einem
impfstoff gegen das corona virus will
die eu mit zusätzlichen geldern fördern
irritierende zahlen zur ausbreitung des
virus kommen aus china
gestern hieß es die zahl der
neuerkrankungen würde sich langsam
stabilisieren
über nacht dann hatte sich diese zahl
der nachgewiesenen infektionen fast
verzehnfacht wegen einer neuen zählweise
insgesamt sind dort jetzt fast 60.000
menschen infiziert aus peking wolle
am tag als die zahlen der infizierten in
die höhe schnellen wollen chinas
machthaber sich handlungsfähig zeigen
militär ärzte und pflegepersonal rücken
nach johann aus ich bin bereit für den
info an haben sich die infektionen mit
dem virus gegenüber dem vortag
verzehnfacht eine neue messmethode sei
der grund ärzte können jetzt eine
diagnose stellen die auf einer
kombination wie lungen bildern und
physischen zustand beruht bisher war ein
dna test nötig der galt als
unzuverlässig
doch wo liegt in der vergangenheit sind
viele patienten nicht entdeckt worden
durch die neue methode können wir sie
jetzt behandelt die virus krise wird
immer mehr zu einem test für präsident
she
der ließ fehler einräume und feuerte den
parteichef von johann vor allem schadet
die angst vor dem virus der chinesischen
wirtschaft die erlebt das langsamste
wachstum in den letzten drei jahrzehnten
der konsum bricht ein großen die kleinen
geschäften fehlen die kunden
wir machen jeden tag verlost
ich hoffe der staat hilft uns bei
steuern und mieter sonst halte ich nicht
mehr lange
vom durchhalten singen chinesische stars
ein lied für hand beschwört die stärke
der nation und der kommunistischen
partei damit das virus nicht das system
infiziert nach deutschland seit einem
jahr durchleuchtet ein
untersuchungsausschuss die sogenannte
berater affäre der bundeswehr
heute kann die letzte und wichtigste
zeugen zu wort
ursula von der leyen früher
verteidigungsministerin jetzt
eu-kommissionspräsident in unter ihr
soll das verteidigungsministerium
mehrere hundert millionen schwere
beraterverträge nicht korrekt vergeben
haben daten auf ihren dienst handys
hätten möglicherweise zur aufklärung
beitragen können wurden aber gelöscht
weniger sie versucht jedes negative bild
von sich zu vermeiden
bevor ursula von der leyen im
untersuchungsausschuss platz nimmt
fliegen die fotografen und kameraleute
aus dem saal nur ein bild von außen von
der zeugen von der leyen der die
opposition hier viele vorwirft aber
schon mit wenig erwartungen in diesem
letzten ausschuss tag gegangen ist
ob der flieger rauskommt wir werden
sehen die hoffnung stirbt bekanntlich
immer zuletzt
aber sicher ist dass frau von der leyen
ministerin war und der ganze
untersuchungszeitraum in ihre minister
zeit auch fällt den hauptvorwurf
vetternwirtschaft weist von der leyen
zurück es habe aber fehler bei der
auftragsvergabe für externe berater
gebieten
es gibt von ihr keinerlei
problembewusstsein über die dinge die
ministerium abgelaufen sind es gibt auch
keine bereitschaft nach wie vor von ihr
konkret verantwortung zu benennen und
auch zu übernehmen
fehler sind nach ihrer ansicht auf der
leitungsebene nicht gemacht worden viele
fragen gibt es auch zu den gelöschten
daten ihres diensthandys von der leyen
hatte bereits an den ausschuss
geschrieben darauf hätten sich keine
vorlage pflichtigen sms befunden
so wiederholt sie es auch heute fazit
nach fünf stunden
wir haben eine ehemalige ministerin
erlebt die zwar im abstrakten von
fehlern sprach sich aber anscheinend nie
die frage gestellt hat wo liegt
eigentlich meinen teil der verantwortung
selbst kritik war ja allenfalls
irgendwie in homöopathischen dosen
erkennbar bei der heutigen befragung vor
einer dreiviertel stunde ging der
ausschuss auseinander und damit auch zu
ende
ursula van der leyen geht ohne
konsequenzen die pkw maut von
verkehrsminister scheuer ist gescheitert
doch den steuerzahler kostet sie
womöglich hunderte millionen euro
heute hörte der zuständige
untersuchungsausschuss den früheren
verkehrsminister ramsauer als zeugen
diese machte kanzlerin merkel und den
damaligen csu-chef seehofer
verantwortlich beide hätten 2013 mit der
spd eine zitat europarechtliche
unmöglichkeit in den koalitionsvertrag
hineinverhandelt der europäische
gerichtshof hatte die maut vergangenes
jahr gestoppt
das wahldebakel von thüringen und die
folgen heute debattierte der bundestag
darüber
fdp chef lindner entschuldigte sich im
namen der liberalen
weil sich sein parteifreund kemmerich
mit afd stimmen zum ministerpräsidenten
wählen ließ die alte wiederum auf den
anderen parteien und demokratisches
handeln vor lasst uns die wellen die die
ministerpräsidentenwahl in erfurt
ausgelöst hat schlagen auch noch im
bundestag hoch fdp chef lindner bekennt
sich klar zu einer mitschuld seiner
partei an der regierungskrise in
thüringen wir sind beschämt weil wir der
afg ermöglicht haben uns und darüber
hinaus die parlamentarische demokratie
zu verhöhnen und dafür entschuldige ich
mich namens der freien demokraten in der
noch die linkspartei wirft cdu fdp und
afd einen gezielten tabubruch
vor ihr wurde es drängt sich aus gz wie
weit man ging fehlverhalten konstatiert
der cdu-generalsekretär auch bei seiner
eigenen partei und macht klar wie er
sich den umgang mit der afg vorstellt
und da gibt es einige die sagen warum
nennt der hütte warum nennt der
cdu-generalsekretär nöthe einen ganz
einfach weil er einer ist weil er
erwiesenermaßen einer ist und sie wissen
es auch die grünen sprechen von einem
tabubruch benennen aber die afg als den
eigentlichen brandstifter die dieses
land nicht die afg dagegen rechtfertigt
ihre wahl eines fdp-kandidaten es ist
auch natürlich und demokratisch dass
eine partei wenn sie sieht dass der
eigene kandidat keine chancen hat einen
anderen ihr immer noch näher stehenden
wählt 1 macht die debatte heute deutlich
zumindest im bundestag waren alle
parteien größtmögliche distanz ofd zur
wirtschaft eigentlich könnte der
europäische flugzeughersteller airbus
sehr zufrieden sein konkurrent boeing
steckt wegen der abstürze und dem
flugverbot für die 737 max in einer
tiefen krise
so konnte airbus das rennen um die
marktführerschaft 2009 10 für sich
entscheiden und hat erstmals seit jahren
wieder mehr verkehrsflugzeuge
ausgeliefert als boeing
trotzdem schreibt der konzern rote
zahlen warum erklärt christel haas es
ist bestimmt kein zufall dass airbus
gerade dieses treibstoffsparende
flugzeugmodell vorgestellt hat der blick
in die zukunft nach einem jahr das
eigentlich glänzend war rekord bei der
auslieferung von passagiermaschinen
marktführerschaft und überquellende
auftragsbücher
ganz unabhängig von der ruhigen flaute
es mag paradox klingen kurzzeitig
profitieren wir nicht von der situation
unseres konkurrenten mit dem a320 sind
wir ausgebucht bis 20.25 heißt
bestellungen von ehemaligen boeing
kunden können nicht mehr angenommen
werden
ein erfolgsjahr wären da nicht die 3,6
milliarden strafe wegen
korruptionsvorwürfen und die export
probleme beim militärtransporter a400m
für die airbus auch deutschland
verantwortlich macht
beim export bekommen wir starken
gegenwind auch wegen des verlängerten
deutschen exportstopps nach saudi
arabien milliardenverlust gleichzeitig
rekord aufträge was heißt das für die
mitarbeiter
es kann eben sein dass dadurch die
produktion noch mal ein bisschen
durcheinander gewirbelt wird und sich
vielleicht im späteren verlauf des
jahres noch mal ein bisschen mehr arbeit
ergibt die größte herausforderung für
airbus jetzt trotz des verlusts schnell
maschinen der zukunft entwickeln um
weiter erfolg zu haben ihre bücher
airbus reagiert im moment mit prototypen
die zum träumen anregen mit diesen
besonderen flügeln aber das verlangt von
airbus sehr große investitionen
und dann ist da noch die sorge über das
corona virus das in chinesischen airbus
werk schon die produktion verzögert hat
wir sind erst am anfang der krise sagte
airbus chef
heute vor genau 75 jahren haben die
alliierten im zweiten weltkrieg dresden
bombardiert mit luftangriffen auf ganze
städte also auch auf zivilisten hatten
die deutschen angefangen mit bomben auf
warschau und auf london etwa ab 1942
schlugen dann briten und amerikaner mit
der gleichen taktik gegen die nazis
zurück zerstörten so viele deutsche
großstädte vor allem hamburg und dann
kurz vor kriegsende dresden fast
vollständig in einer nacht 25.000
menschen starben
anja chalet über den tag des gedenkens
vor der wiederaufgebauten frauenkirche
dem symbol dresden schließen sich
tausende zu einer menschenkette zusammen
mittendrin bundespräsident steinmeier 75
jahre nach der zerstörung dieser stadt
stehen sie hier
dass so etwas nie wieder passiert am 13
februar 1945 hatten britische bomber
dresden kurz vor ende des zweiten
weltkriegs beinahe vollständig in schutt
und asche gelegt
bis zu 25.000 menschen starben ein tag
der hier noch immer allgegenwärtig ist
gedenken tag und unerträglich wenn der
gedenkt auch von anderer seite für einen
abend wird dann muss daran denken dass
so etwas nie wieder passieren darf
das ist die hauptsache im dresdner
kulturpalast erinnert bundespräsident
steinmeier an das leid vieler deutscher
städte im bombenkrieg und benennt die
ursachen dazu führten wir vergessen
nicht
es waren deutsche die diesen grausamen
krieg begonnen haben es waren
schließlich millionen deutsche die in
fürthen nicht alle aber doch viele aus
überzeugung nie wieder ist der auftrag
der überlebenden so steinmeier
und so warnt er vor fremdenfeindlichkeit
vor antisemitismus und davor die
versucht werde den rechtsstaat
verächtlich zu machen wenn gewählte
abgeordnete heute die parlamente in
denen sie sitzen vorführen und
lächerlich machen dann ist das der
versuch demokratie von innen zu
zerstören
mehrere tausend stehen an diesem abend
in dresden dafür ein wachsam zu sein
dass sich geschichte nicht wiederholt
durch einen mutmaßlich rassistisch
motivierten brandanschlag ist ein
restaurant in syke bei bremen zerstört
worden
der staatsschutz ermittelt an dem
gebäude wurden zwei hakenkreuze und der
spruch ausländer raus entdeckt betreiber
des restaurants ist ein sieg mit
migrationshintergrund deshalb geht die
polizei von einem fremdenfeindlichen
hintergrund aus ganz anderes thema jetzt
frauen in der kunst galten lange zeit
vor allem als quelle der inspiration
waren kunstobjekte aber nicht
kunstschaffende fantastische frauen
zeigt eine andere realität mit frida
kahlo und 33 weiteren künstlerinnen
präsentiert die schirn kunsthalle in
frankfurt erstmals den weiblichen
beitrag zum surrealismus sehr sehenswert
findet andrea meuser
sie waren geliebte modelle und musen und
sie waren künstlerinnen erst bekannt
später vergessen
jetzt will die ausstellung in der schirn
sie diesem vergessen entreißen und
präsentiert die frauen im surrealismus
künstlerinnen auf ihrem eigenen weg die
begierde die erotik die sexualität und
insbesondere auch die männerfantasien
vom frauenkörper stehen natürlich im
zentrum des männlichen surrealismus aber
sie stehen auch im zentrum des
weiblichen zu realismus insofern ist es
interessant zu sehen wie eigentlich die
künstlerinnen mit dem thema weiblicher
sexualität mit dem eigenen ich umgehen
und so ist es der weibliche körper der
diese ausstellung dominiert oder um es
anders zu sagen der weibliche blick auf
den weiblichen körper
viele der werke erzählen von der suche
nach eigener identität und dem
selbstverständnis als frau es sind
bekannte themen aber es ist ein neuer
weiblicher blickwinkel die frauen
wandstärke damit konfrontiert zu fragen
wer bin ich als frau war bin ich als
künstlerin was ist mein lebensweg und
sie mussten größere widerstände
überwinden
dadurch sind die werke vielleicht
spannungsvoller spannungsvoll oft auch
ironisch gerne selbstbewusst
und häufig auf der suche nach neuen
formen auf jeden fall eine ausstellung
nicht nur für frauen
da guck mal bis 24 mai in frankfurt am
main von fantastischen frauen zu einem
fantastischen ski rennläufer ja und zwar
zu einem glückskind am 13 februar mit
startnummer 13 an diesem donnerstag hat
thomas dreesen erneut bewiesen dass er
zu den ganz großen abfahrtsläufer in der
gegenwart gehört mit seinem dritten
saisonsieg in saalbach hinterglemm trotz
eines missgeschicks gleich nach dem
start die abfahrt beginnt artistisch für
thomas dreesen dass sie nicht stets ein
weltcup wegen des kroner virus von china
nach österreich verlegt wir für dresen
im letzten drittel zum sportlichen
husarenritt vor dem schweizer wertvoll
dem bang sieger auf platz zwei einfach
das was mit die dreher besprochen heißt
und ist perfekt aufgegangen
thomas dresden ist damit der erste
deutsche überhaupt der zweimal
nacheinander eine weltcup abfahrt
gewinnen kann
frust im ziel medaille verpasst für
schlussläufer benedikt doll reicht es
mit der mixed staffel nur zu platz vier
zum auftakt der biathlon
weltmeisterschaften in antholz in
südthüringen darf deutsche mix quartett
hatte mit einer medaille geliebäugelt am
ende jedoch das podest klar verfehlt
rang vier bei der wm geht schon um die
medaillen vom vierten platz kann man
dienst sich dann doch noch nicht so viel
kaufen
die schlüsselszene dieses rennens der
stehendanschlag der zweiten läuferinnen
denise herrmann schießt eine strafrunde
deutschland fällt zurück auf rang acht
trotz aufholjagd der männer die
podestplätze sind außer reichweite
die norweger verteidigen ihren wm-titel
gastgeber italien startet mit silber
bronze für tschechien nach dem spontanen
rücktritt von jürgen klinsmann als
trainer bei hertha bsc hat der klub
reagiert wie es zu erwarten war eine
fortsetzung der kooperation im
aufsichtsrat ist bis auf weiteres
ausgeschlossen
leider muss ich sagen dass heute
aufgrund der art und weise wie der
jürgen klinsmann sich verabschiedet hat
eine zusammenarbeit unmittelbar jetzt
weiter mit ihm im aufsichtsrat der
hertha bsc aus meiner sicht
nicht vorstellbar ist in weniger als 80
tagen aus der berliner fußball welt beim
wetter sind weiterhin schnee und regen
angesagt aber es wird langsam trocken
die details gleich von osten terry 15
meldet sich claus kleber mit dem heute
journal
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das tief tores ist
noch über deutschland und bringt regen
hier in blau eingefärbt und in weiß den
schnee vor allem hierüber der
alpenregion da schneit es auch länger
anhaltend
aber wir bekommen ein neues hoch und das
bringt auch deutlich mildere luft und
beruhigung mit schauen denn die nacht
schneite es bis auf 500 meter in den
mittelgebirgen runter und an den alpen
bis auf 1000 meter und hier kann es
kräftiger schneiden und länger
und dann sind 25 zentimeter neuschnee
gut möglich ganz im norden da wird es
bereits trockener und die temperaturen
sinken auf null grad im vogtland und 1
grad an den alpen sieben grad sind es im
südwesten deutschlands morgen
tagesverlauf wir werden regen und schnee
allmählich weniger und es zieht ab im
westen lockert es auf einige sonnige
abschnitte da sind dabei und ganz im
norden da ist es am freundlichsten mit
temperaturen zwischen vier grad im
vogtland und an den alpen und 11 im
südwesten
es geht aber noch milder am samstag bis
14 grad etwas regen im norden und
sonntag wir haben eigentlich noch
hochwinter beziehungsweise spät winter
bis 20 grad sturm und regen ein schöner
abend